يبدو ان الامور تسير باتجاه توقعات اكثر
تفاؤلا في تنفيذ هذه الصفقه لكن ثم عثرات
حتى اللحظه نستمع من ذلك الى تصريحات من
اليمين المتطرف نستمع الى لهجه حاده من
طرف نتنياهو فسرت من مسؤول امريكي بحسب
وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه على انها وجهه
نظر اليمين وليس وجهه نظر نتنياهو هل معنى
ذلك ان نتنياهو اقر
الصفقه نعم تحياتي استاذ نشو وصباح الخير
يعني بطبيعه الحال ربما هنا تجدر الاشاره
الى موقف بين مين
نتنياهو الكلاسيكي الذي كان معتمدا تحديدا
ما قبل الهدنه الاولى عشيه تلك الهدنه
نتنياهو كان يصف بان كل ما يجري من عمليه
عسكريه هو الامر المقدس ولا مناص الا
العمليه العسكريه لاعاده الاسرى وما الى
ذلك وفي ليله وضحاها نتنياهو يغير الشريط
ويبدا يغرد بان العمليه العسكريه هي اي
عفوا الصفقه هي الامر المقدس الذي يجب ان
يكون لكي تكون هنالك اعاده الاسر وان هذه
الصفقه هي امر محتم وامر مقدس وما الى ذلك
الان هنالك جزئيه هنالك الاهم التي تجري
في الايام الثلاثه الاخيره بنيمين نتنياهو
ركز اكثر من اي شيء اخر يعني بعيدا عن ان
لم يكن هنالك الكثير من التسريبات
والشائعات في داخل اسرائيل بل على العكس
من ذلك حاول ان يحتوي ذلك الموقف بغض
النظر عن ما قاله لذوي الاسرى بانه مستعد
حتى ان يفكك ايه ايه حكومته اذا كان هنالك
اي امر يعرض الامن على ان تكون هنالك صفقه
لاعاده الاسر وهذا هو الامر الاهم بالنسبه
اليه لكن على طول هذه الفتره كان يغرد
لليمين بما يطرب اذنيه لن يكون هنالك
تحرير لاسرى فلسطينيين ذوي قيمه واسامي
ذات قيمه من جهه ومن جهه اخرى كذلك ان لن
يكن هنالك اسرى بالالاف هذه تحديدا ربما
يجب ان ناخذها باعتبارات بنيامين نتنياهو
عندما يضخم الارقام بنيامين نتنياهو هذا
او يضخم الحدث بطبيعه الحال هو يحاول ان
يصغر من النتيجه في نهايه المطاف لانه وفق
الصفقه يعني غالبا كل السيناريوهات يتحدث
عن مئات ولا تتحدث عن الاف بنيامين
نتنياهو يخرج ويتحدث عن الاف يحاول ان
يهول هول الصفقه امام الشارع اليميني بكل
معنى الكلمه هذا مشهد كلاسيكي قام به في
اكثر من موقف في في في ا الاحيان كان يقوم
بكل هذا الحدث ايه وبهذه الاستراتيجيه
فواضح جدا انه يحاول تسويق واداره علاقات
عامه واداره الازمه امام اليمين لكي يمهد
له كل نتاج هذه المرحله هذا في المقام
الاول كذلك نبره الاداره الامريكيه في
اكثر من موقف وبعيدا عن هذه الجزئيه التي
كانت هنا في اكثر من موقف الاداره
الامريكيه كانت تقول انه يمكن لبنيامين
تانيا ان يصرح ما يشاء يعني قلتها على
الاقل في على مرتين في ال في الثلاثه ايام
الاخيره يمكنه ان يصرح ما يشاء ولكن هنالك
اعتبارات عليا هي التي
ايه تكتب الحدث في هذه المرحله بما معناه
فبالتالي واضح جدا ان تراكميه المشهد ما
يجري في داخل كل هذه الاثناء من مشاهد
اقليميه من مشاهد حتى في داخل اسرائيل ان
كانت اقتصاديه ان كانت ب عسكريه بطبيعه
الحال ميدانيه وسياسيه بطبيعه الحال كل
هذه الامور وكل هذه الضغوطات لها زخمها
الاكبر مما يمكن ان ان يكتب او يملي
اليمين ومنهم على يمين بنيمين نتنياهو
بطبيعه الحال من ضغوطات
على ربما ربما ربما يعني اسمح لي يعني
ربما واحد من من اكثر الاسئله الحاحا هل
سيقوم نتنياهو بالتنازل عن بعض اهداف
الحرب سيناريوهات الخروج هذه الامور التي
يقوم بها بمين نتنياهو حتى في الصفقه
الاولى كان لديه سيناريو خروج وح و في
الاربعه ايام الاولى او السته ايام الاولى
تحديدا جس نبض حماس واخضاع حماس وارغامها
بالتلاعب ب بمعايير الصفقه كي تقوم هي
بفضل الصفقه لكنه في اليوم الثامن قام هو
بفضلها بطبيعه الحال سيناريوهات الخروج هي
احد الامور الكلاسيكيه التي سوف يبحث عنها
بنيامين نتنياهو في المقام الاول في
المقام الثاني لديه مراهنه اخرى لديه كذلك
هذا الامر يجب ان اخذ بعين الاعتبار اي
نعم بان سوتش وبينغ فير يحاولان الان من
ان
يعني يذكران بنم نتنياهو بالخطوط الحمر
التي لا يجب ان يتخطاها باي شكل من
الاشكال ولكن في نهايه المطاف الكل يعلم
في اسرائيل ان هذه الحكومه لربما تكون
الحكومه الاخيره التي يتواجد بها سمتش
وبين فير بغض النظر عن عدد المقاعد التي
يمكن ان يجلبان في الحكومه القادمه في
الكنيست القادمه عفوا هذه قد تكون الحكومه
الاولى على الاقل في الخمس او عشره حتى
سنوات القادمه وبالتالي لديهم شباك زمني
قصير ذهابهم لفض هذ هذه الحكومه بطبيعه
الحال هو بمثابه عمليه انتحاريه بالنسبه
ليهم ولذلك ولهذا السبب تحديدا هم
سيحاولون تماما كما بنيامين نتنياهو من
اطاله عمر هذه الحكومه بابتزاز بنيامين
نتنياهو على المدى الاطول بطبيعه الحال
حتى لو ذهب الى وقف اطلاق النار نقل ذلك
بكلمات جدا بسيطه اليمين المتطرف
الايديولوجي سوتش وبين فير هذا المعسكر لا
يعنيه وقف اطلاق النار من عدمه في نهايه
المطاف حتى بمث بالخدمه العسكريه بطبيعه
الحال لا يوجد ليهم ذلك الاثر والتاثير
الكبير بمفهوم الخدمه العسكريه كل ما يعني
هذا اليمين في نهايه المطاف هو الاستيطان
والمشروع الاستيطان ولهذا السبب اذا اردنا
ان نعود الى يوم الاحد ما كان يوم الاحد
في المؤتمر الاخير هم قرنوا الاستيطان في
قطاع غزه بشمالي الضفه الغربيه بكلمات
اخرى ان المراهنه والابتزاز والورقه
الاصعب التي سوف يضعونها امام بنيامين
نتنياهو هي الاستيطان وتكثيف الاستيطان في
شمالي الضفه الغربيه وكذلك هنالك ورقه
اخرى الت يعلم بيمين نتنياهو انه سوف يخضع
لها في نهايه المطاف امام هذا اليمين هي
كل جزئيه حل الدول سيد جبارين يعني اسمح
لي بلحظات البنتاجون بحسب خبر عاجل يقول
ان الوزير اوستن بحث في اتصال هاتفي مع
نظر الاسرائيلي تحول اسرائيل الى عمليات
عسكريه اقل حده في غزه هذا مع عدم تناسي
او نسيان التصريحات تصريحات جالت الاخيره
بان ع عين الجيش الاسرائيلي على على رفح
وهذا الخطاب التصعيدي بالاضافه الى خطاب
تصعيدي اشد نبره من سموتريش الذي قال ان
الصفقه لن لن تحدث هل يمكن الاخذ في
الاعتبار ل هذذه
التصريحات انا بطبيعه الحال باعتقاد ان
هنالك املاءات اكبر من مما يرغب به سوتش
وجلن في نهايه المطاف ب على العكس من هذا
كله انا باعتقادي ان جالانت ما كان يحاول
ان يقوم به بتصريحات في السطر الاخير هي
محاوله ل تسويقيه للنزول من على
الشجره بطبيعه الحال يعني اذا اخدنا
تراكميه او تسلسل تصريحات جلان في الايام
الاخيره هي
بمثابه تصريحات تحاول ان تصور وتصدر
للشارع الاسرائيلي صوره بطوليه وصوره نصر
يستطيع ان يعني يهضمها في نهايه المطاف
حتى وان ذهبت اسرائيل الى صفقه كهذه او كا
اخرى هذا باعتقادي في المقام الاول
بالنسبه لسمو في نهايه المطاف مره اخرى
يمكن سمتش و
ل لبن بير التصريح بما يشاؤون بداخل هذه
الفتره انا باعتقادي ان كل هذه التصريحات
هي مجرد املاءات ابتزاز امام بنيامين
نتنياهو سوف يضعها وكذلك نقطه مهمه جدا
بنيامين نتنياهو لن يدعهم باي شكل من
الاشكال يعني هذه كذلك نقطه يجب ان
نتذكرها بان يخرجوا عن طوعه ويخرجوا عن
ائتلافه باعتقادي هذه كذلك مراوغه يعني
يقوم بها بنيمين نتنياهو لان خروجهم عن
طوعه يعني بكلمات اخرى وجع راس سوف ينتظر
بنيامين نتنياهو بكميات اكبر مما ينتظرهم
الان في داخل ارقه المعارضه بل العكس
تماما ولا يستطيع ان يجلس في داخل الحكومه
اصلا تركيبتها يعني هي وجع راس بمضاعف من
جهه سوتش وبينغ فير حلفائه او على الاقل
يعني
الشص المعسكر الذي يجد به حضنا متواجد في
في المعارضه وائتلاف مكون من كل الشخصيات
التي كانت تعارضه على مدار عام كامل اي
مساله الثقه كذلك سوف تكون على المحك بكل
هذه المشهديه ولهذا السبب انا باعتقادي
انه سوف يحاول ان يبقي على سش وب حتى وان
اتى لبيد واعطاه شبكه الامان في داخل من
حيف الكاتب المختص في الشان الاسرائيلي
ايهاب جبارين شكرا لك